the new study is showing that people are
exhausted when it comes to Facebook 27%
of Facebook users that were just
surveyed said they plan to spend less
time on Facebook in the next year where
do you guys fall out on this social
media thing are you exhausted has it
sucked the life out of you
Jacki we'll start with you no no I mean
I like Twitter a lot more it's just
easier and more fun I think but I like
that you can hide people now on Facebook
which is good from the timeline so you
can make it a little bit that's just
yeah yeah so it's a little less
exhausting mm-hmm Dave what do you think
are you falling by tebow I fantasize
about deleting my Facebook account every
single day yeah I really do I'm sick to
death of it and if I didn't have the
thing if it I'd have shows to promote
yeah I would be on I can't handle it
anymore I could I don't want to play
anything ville with you or anyone you
know my request is crazy I'm sick of
being tagged as a shoe I can't if you
send me another bad bedazzled Nike
platform stiletto thing I really am
going to come to your house and punch
you because I can find out where you
live through some Facebook it's
interesting because we're all talking
about Facebook they're saying about
Facebook this sort of inner world of
your you're friends with your mom and
then you know somebody that maybe saw
you do a comedy show or somebody that
has she requested you and you see her
and usually you just leave her that
[ __ ] got blocked see but that's how
people are that's how my mother is and
that's how my sister is they know what
I'm doing every moment of the day
because they are friends with all my
friends who drop dimes on me without it
without a blink of an eye
Marcellus was out last night making it
wrong either straight making rain at a
strip club Marcellus said blah blah blah
blah blah more so this is voting
Republican it's like literally you never
know what's gonna happen but Clarisse
will call me up and be like on Facebook
you said how do you know I blocked you
well your friend Tanika follows me and
that's how I know because she was with
you I guess I got a blocked Anika now
Jackie what so do you think Twitter is a
little bit easier because Twitter sorta
more like one way we're just putting
stuff out there and you can interact if
you so choose but it's not like your
your personal life you're a big foodie
picture III and I like to describe I
like to describe my pictures ever mind
my food in 140 characters or less I
really do I mean it's it's good it's
it's it's a good it's a good writers
workout I did a little little quiche
with some some sweet potato and
mushrooms now the question is have you
change the evening the process of eating
you know what I mean you cooked you put
together something great you played it
real nice and then the first thing is
you got to take a picture that's foreign
food for everyone oh my god you can't do
something you can't just lead a life
anymore without it being documented but
in 140 characters or by a picture yeah I
mean you have to come up with something
myself in 11 years because I won't be
close to like Twitter but you know like
that's just fit it's something if the
world ends how will I know it won't be
because the world is ending and the
buildings are falling down around me it
will be because Twitter will have let me
know you know but I'm going to get it
from the verified source like Gawker or
Huffington Post yeah so the question is
this
what do we do if we're all feeling this
endless fatigue with all this stuff but
we can't stop it you haven't had a
private thought in 11 years
you're you're instagramming as we're as
we're sitting here what are we gonna do
to control the beast Jackie what do we
do just to control our endless abyss Big
Brother isn't it like they know
everything that we're doing and you know
instead of Big Brother we're like
actually being like we were here I was
there like we're doing it for them
kindness just makes [ __ ] so much
easier what do we do I don't know you
can delete your account you could turn
your friends into fans my friend Paige
go to my fanpage you're my friend fan me
they won't do I know Dan cook he turned
his you know friends into fit enough
fans and friends yeah so the opposite he
turned his fans into friends I did I
change the the friends into fans thing
and you get a lot of people angry at you
yeah something that I did for a little
while which is sort of like observe the
Sabbath in a way you know what I mean
just unplug like on a Sunday just no
screens yeah you know I mean close your
laptop answer phones on a calls on your
phone and that's it no texting no
tweeting no nothing and you know it
makes you talk to people in real life
which is unpleasant but it's
you